getting to those goals.
Is that my sense?
And the platform breakdown.
That's in historicals.
OK.
And then would we keep those percentages based off of the historicals or what we're seeing train like because obviously, Google and Meta have been like 50% the last 30 days.
Do not do not use the historicals as anything but a spend reference.
for like the growth changes and you can that like because that's the whole thing is like I don't want our strategy to be grounded in historical strategy.
I don't think we're going to get to where we want to be that way.
So once we know where we're going and what we need to happen, then we can sort of fine tune how we get there.
And then you'll have like, you know, the actually, let me move these into here.
June goes into Q2.
And then July gets Q3.
Does this make sense of what I'm doing?
Yeah.
And then you'll basically have one of these
You don't need to go into individual month by month unless you want to.
It might be helpful.
I don't know your processes.
And then just so you know, when I build these, I just carry over the direct and organic from the previous year, just as reference, because we don't know what that's going to do.
We can build the month by month together if you want to.
So yeah, now that you know like what I'm trying to do, what part of it do you feel like you can take on?
Yeah, the definitely the Q1 or Q4 summaries, like that all makes sense.
I mean, obviously, I'll just be adding the last few.
I would say like just the channel breakdown would be the only thing I'm like a little iffy on just cuz I really stab at it don't know like I'm definitely confident and taking a stab at it but I wouldn't want to review it and just see like what you think would be best as well cuz even just getting a glimpse into it the other day when you're coming up with not a spin for the month of July.
and just figure out the channel, like what do we want channel performance to be?
So that was insightful, but just want to make sure we're aligned there.
But yeah, I think the summary is, I'll be able to do it.
Yeah, and honestly, I think the part that you're saying you need help with is the part that's the most, is gonna have the most fluctuation.
And I also don't think it makes sense for us to do it in a vacuum without Sharma.
So what I would do, and actually this is, I think I did this for June, okay.
in these individual summaries, and then we can probably do it.
Yeah, so like in here, so let's just do this now for July.
It's actually paid search is what I'm going to call this.
And then this will be, oh, whoops, this is paid social.
And then there's paid search.
And then actually there should be lead gen or like, what are we calling this?
Gen, like,
Demand Gen is my brain.
So that's like, Demand Gen is all the top of funnel.
Right?
So for YouTube, right?
Like that's paid.
That's what they call it on YouTube.
But like, we can also use Demand Gen on CTV.
That's it.
And I would say for me, this whole bucket is like your awareness bucket and like the things that are not strictly tied to like a row as it is meant to like fuel the ecosystem.
These two are like the more row as and cack oriented.
So that might might help you.
Again, I actually don't care that much about you making this perfect like these.
separations perfect.
It's more like, here's how much money we have to spend, here's how much affiliate gets, and here's how much charmer gets, or we get when we manage the other channels.
Okay.
Okay, so let's just, yeah, take a stab at this.
Let me, want me to input directly.
Just here, here, and I'll input.
But Chris is going to give me those numbers right now, and then I'll input them.
How are you doing?
Good, good, good, good.
That's something.
It won't make sense.
Not too overwhelming, so.
Okay.
Cool.
Are you good?
Um, and then I always obviously just like keep track of these efficiencies.
Oh, my husband like unplugged my computer.
Yeah, let's start here and then I'll create a separate conversation around, around Amazon.
Yeah, because I noticed that I was on that weekly report, but I didn't have any like, I didn't have a tool to kind of view that performance or any log ins either.
Yeah, so Amazon, just while Chris is doing this, Amazon is interesting because we sell to a reseller.
So we basically have like, it's run like a wholesale.
partner.
That might change.
I had a really good conversation with another agency.
I like this current one.
It's just the unit economics are starting to not make as much sense because it's grown it.
So it's possible that we take it in-house but have a sort of 3P
partner, how experienced are you on Amazon?
So I've always had partners on Amazon, never really directly managing myself, but I'm familiar with the wholesale process through talking through them.
But they've all directly managed it and kind of handled logistics, making sure the product and stuff is there.
So definitely never manage it, but familiar with how it plays into the ecosystem.
Yeah.
So I think for now, I can keep just managing it for now.
And then I think the D2C one is the one I need the most help with.
So we can focus on that.
And then I'll add you in if we make a major change or something.
OK.
And then I can also work on getting those CRM inputs for you for each month, because you're not going to have that.
here.
Cool CRM and what would the CRM
That's just like email and SMS.
So we come from claveo and attentive and then we just move to post script, but that won't have any of the historicals.
I think a half access to the claveo and attentive.
Oh, you do.
Okay.
Great.
So we're going to be good there where I can pull it from Northland to Rural.
I mean, we want platform reported revenue, right?
So it makes these reports the easiest.
Definitely.
And then, um,
The only thing with CRM, you can confirm this, but like for July, I'm pretty sure I used the Shopify reported revenue versus the Clavio because the Shopify one is the most conservative.
It's like the last click.
But I can't.
How's revenue reporting for Clavio?
Yes.
Let me actually see what I used.
I'm wondering if I have it here.
There's a marketing channels report and other marketing and attribution.
Does that sound familiar?
Oh, um, here.
Share your screen with me here.
I'll stop sharing.
Yes, so you can just like do Clavio just make sure that you're using all of the iterations or maybe like more than one.
And then there's also in the analytics, there's like sales buy refer.
But no, I think you're right with the marketing channel.
That's going to be the cleanest.
Marking attribution.
Yeah, I'm looking at it too on my own thing.
There's a few different ones.
Yeah, Marking attribution might wrap them all into one so not to filter down to it, but I'll swap in some both.
Yeah, you can also just ask Hannah at Sharma who does our CRM.
But I'm pretty sure I used the Shopify number.
And I think Hannah just gave it to me.
So yeah, here's Clevio.
Let me actually go out for computers and soul.
Hmm, last year.
time.
So yeah, here we go.
Flavio.
Oh, see, this is saying 90.
Oh, right.
It would be clavio and then attentive.
So I probably did that 90 plus whatever we can get there.
Let's see.
Did Christopher
Okay, and then for these guys, let me show you guys.
You can just use GA4 for the direct and organic.
Okay.
And I just pull a revenue from those channels from direct and organic.
Perreference.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, that makes sense.
Jordan, you're a mute.
Yeah, no, it makes sense.
We're good to go.
Okay, okay, cool.
Chris hasn't gotten back to me, but yeah, this is the exercise.
So kind of like look at the last year and then look at this year.
And then that's also really good grounding for you too of like what basically drove each month.
We've also added a bunch of new channels and stuff like that.
So it'll get a little bit more interesting.
I also have anesthesia, so I'm going to give the affiliate investment parts here.
Anesthesia handles the affiliate relationships.
Yeah.
OK.
Okay, anything else you need for me?
I just want to walk through, make sure I understand correctly.
So looking at the worksheet or historicals to get historical data to pull in to Q1 through Q4 or Q3 through Q4 summaries.
Looking at 2022, 2023 or 23, 24, 25 of the last three years.
We want growth from year over year, approximately 20% is kind of what we're projecting for the future months.
And then also looking at channel breakdown performance and getting some budgets there too.
But what's really important is the overall budget for each quarter so that we know what we're working with.
Exactly, so I would start.
here, right?
I like go into, you'll actually have the historicals all here.
And then we just need to, so let me actually, just to stop from being confusing, I'm going to delete this, because we don't have these actuals yet.
And you're gonna, I wouldn't even put these actuals in here until we have them.
So like leave this sheet just with like what really happened.
And then use our Q2 and then the monthlies, you know, Q3, Q4 and then the monthlies for the projections.
So you'll have this.
I'm going to put in the actuals so that you can determine.
OK.
Lean.
Good, good, good.
And this is also set up by PPC and affiliate.
This is so annoying.
This is old.
You're really actually going to do, it's this one.
a combined is this breaks up to oops.
Because this is really what you need.
sales and then combine spend.
You may end up wanting to recreate this really.
I don't know.
Sorry, I'm thinking about this out loud.
Chris went in to all these stupid formulas.
And then actually what maybe we're missing here is like here to date on these quarterly ones because this will be your summary.
sales, spend, percent of gold.
Are you filming?
Yeah.
So you're going to try to fix how close or far are we?
You'll need all the summaries.
And then just in terms of like projection language versus actuals, whenever you do a projection, just put in a different color or like highlight the cell or something like that.
So it just keeps it clean.
And then we'll probably just need one of these for each month within that quarter.
Let me just make them now.
And you for these the individual month ones you just need 24 and there you don't need 23.
And then this is what we get to Sharma too.
that everything I do is now just make sense.
I only started this in June because we were like ramping up and everything was kind of chaotic, but now it'll help.
Okay.
I think we're good.
Let's check if Chris.
No, we are all right.
I'll just put it in when Chris ends it.
Sounds good.
Let me know when that's when.
Thank you.
All right.
Talk soon.
I'll go.